ah
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález el
presidente de rusia vladimir putin en un
mensaje a la nación tras haber sostenido
un consejo de seguridad de emergencia
reconoció el estatus de independencia de
las autodenominadas repúblicas populares
del done jets y lugansk estas son dos
regiones en el este de ucrania tienen
fronteras precisamente con la federación
de rusia y tienen una población de
mayoría rusoparlante y son importantes
ejes industriales para la economía de
ucrania
escuchemos las palabras del presidente
putin de ese momento cuando reconoce la
autodeterminación de estas dos
repúblicas en la región del donbass
raymond creo que es necesario tomar una
decisión muy esperada reconocer
inmediatamente la independencia y la
soberanía de la república popular de
dónetsk y la república popular de
lugares que nadie discute pido a la
asamblea federal de la federación rusa
que apoye esta decisión y que luego
ratifique los tratados de amistad y
asistencia mutua con ambas repúblicas de
komi si el interés público
el presidente putin elaboró varios
argumentos para justificar esta decisión
indicó que la situación actual en la
región del donbass es absolutamente
insostenible pero también se remontó a
varios argumentos históricos escuchemos
resultado racing ballistic y la ucrania
soviética surgió gracias a la política
bolchevique y en nuestros días todavía
puede llamarse con razón la ucrania de
lenin él es el autor y el arquitecto los
documentos de archivo lo confirman
completa y totalmente incluyendo las
audaces directivas de lenin sobre el
donbass que fue literalmente metido en
el cuerpo de ucrania y ahora los
descendientes han demolido los
monumentos de lenin en ucrania lo llaman
des comunicación quieren ser des
comunicados pues nos parece muy bien
pero no se queden a mitad de camino
estamos dispuestos a mostrarles lo que
significa realmente des comunicar a
ucrania de comunicarse en sus redes
durante casi una hora habló el
presidente putin en cadena nacional y
durante ese espacio también criticó
fuertemente a las autoridades ucranianas
por su incapacidad en la construcción de
un estado fuerte según putin la
corrupción ha dañado la capacidad
industrial del país ha jugado también en
contra de la prosperidad y la calidad de
vida de los ciudadanos ucranianos y por
eso 6 millones de ellos han tenido que
dejar el país en la última década para
buscar mejores condiciones de vida en
otros puntos de europa y del mundo los
anuncios hechos por el kremlin dejan
muchas preguntas sobre la mesa vamos a
analizar entonces el alcance de esta
decisión y las respuestas que puede
haber a nivel internacional para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a
indicó et sigue de masca que ella es
doctora en sociología jurídica e
instituciones políticas es experta en
temas de la unión europea y de
cooperación internacional del docente en
la pontificia universidad javeriana ya
se encuentra en la ciudad de bogotá pero
es ciudadana húngara también está con
nosotros desde la ciudad de parís en
francia rodrigo murillo
novelista peruano historiadora analista
político internacional ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con todos sus comentarios
y sus preguntas no pueden hacer a través
de las redes sociales no se encuentran
en facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24 guión bajo s
arroba sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo la etiqueta
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios empiezo entonces con
indicó en la ciudad de bogotá en la
capital colombiana preguntándole por sus
impresiones a esta decisión tomada por
el presidente de rusia vladimir putin
respaldado por completo por la duma
estatal que es la cámara baja del
parlamento ruso y que hizo este anuncio
en un discurso de un poco más de una
hora ante toda la federación
buenas tardes estar con ustedes en este
momento es desde la semana pasada y
justamente le digo al presidente a la
tumba que todavía vayan guardando está
esta propuesta y lo que la duma iba a
presentar y en efecto lo presentó esta
semana entonces a putin sobre el
reconocimiento de
strasser desde estos territorios
orientales de ucrania es una situación
muy triste si uno lo mira desde el punto
de vista de otra intervención
supremamente fuerte uno está sintiendo
que estamos repitiendo la situación de
2014 de crimea si uno quiere pensar en
una forma positiva por otro lado y es lo
que yo quiero hacer es lo que yo estoy
esperando por eso por eso es que puede
ser una salida para putin en una
situación donde todo el mundo dice que
va a iniciar la guerra
dios quiera que no inicia la guerra pero
anexando estos territorios se puede como
que sellar este conflicto eso no está
bien en ningún
momento se puede decir que eso estaría
bien pero si se podría evitar una guerra
directa y lo que podría como ir a
escalándose entonces en toda ucrania y
quien sabe hacia donde más
veces o puede ser una solución clara
rodrigo en la ciudad de parís en francia
su opinión perspectivas de lo que ha
dicho el presidente putin en la jornada
de hoy que tiene al mundo entero con
reacciones en washington en bruselas
también en varios países de europa del
este por supuesto en ucrania
buenas tardes para ustedes santiago y
también para indicó es un placer
acompañarlos bueno desde la perspectiva
ucraniana seguramente se ha consumado
tras el mensaje presidencial de vladimir
putin una mutilación inaceptable de su
territorio para ucrania es ciertamente
no escuchan en kiev los argumentos
históricos
recargados de nostalgia podríamos decir
de vladimir putin esto es una agresión
militar y constituye el sello como decía
inaceptable de una invasión militar para
la perspectiva de moscú podríamos decir
que es el paso natural es la consumación
final de una política pues
agresiva liderada por vladimir putin
para
recuperar de cierta forma presentando
hechos consumados la prestancia militar
y geopolítica
la nueva rusia es importante señalar que
en el mensaje de vladimir putin lo que
hoy
es el reconoce el reconocimiento de las
repúblicas de dones y lugares no
incorpora por el momento una anexión una
absorción para la federación rusa algo
distinto a lo que sucedió con la anexión
de crimea pero indudablemente marca pues
un acercamiento mucho más importante de
la influencia vía militar rusa en estos
territorios de cara a una ucrania pero
también unión europea y eeuu que no han
terminado de ponerse de acuerdo respecto
de la estrategia
implementada para efectivamente limitar
las medidas hasta ahora unilaterales de
moscú
indicó en el marco del derecho
de lo que puede ser el marco de la
constitución ucraniana de la
constitución rusa y de el derecho
internacional para la gente del donbass
que significa este reconocimiento y bajo
qué autoridad entonces están los
ciudadanos ahora bajo qué autoridad
estatal digámoslo así para los ojos de
ucrania siguen siendo dos regiones
importantes para ucrania pero para el
kremlin y para moscú y para esa
población rusoparlante y étnicamente
rusa del este de ucrania ya fueron
reconocidos a nivel internacional por lo
menos por este país por la federación
lo que pasa es y es la comunidad
internacional y tendría que reconocer la
independencia de un territorio lo que
después podría convertirse en un país
independiente
entonces y pues obviamente para los
granos estos territorios siguen siendo
parte de ucrania por otro lado pues los
rusos como tú dices muy bien eso no
significa que sería ya parte de rusia
pero hay el reconocimiento de la
independencia de un territorio se
requiere de reconocimiento de la
comunidad internacional lo que no va a
ocurrir yo de otros de otros modos yo
quiero añadir algo
económicamente la influencia de las
oligarcas rusas en este territorio de
ucrania
desde hace que existió la unión
soviética y sigue y ucrania
independiente eso estaba presente todo
el mundo sabía que hay no se hace
negocio si uno no está con los rusos
significa que es es muchísimo más
profundo y muchísimo más difícil pero
que era conocimiento de la comunidad
internacional no va a venir ahí muy
interesante si va a pronunciarse china
en frente de sé qué voy a decir sí y que
van a decir los demás países que son
cercanos a rusia sobre esta
determinación del kremlin que ha sido
anunciada hace algunas horas y rodrigo
vale la pena especificar y profundizar
en lo que significa y es algo que ya
estaba tocando indicó la importancia de
estas dos regiones lo decía yo en la
introducción son regiones industriales
importantes para la economía ucraniana
que lleva muchos años muy afectadas sin
poder despegar por completo y eso ha
llevado a que muchos ciudadanos
ucranianos se hayan tenido que ir del
país buscando mejores condiciones pero
allí es donde estaba concentrada la
productividad industrial heredada
precisamente de la unión soviética que
significa entonces para ucrania si estas
dos regiones se separan por completo si
definitivamente ucrania las pierde que
significaría para quién
bueno para que
significaría como lo dije en mi primera
intervención una mutilación inaceptable
de su territorio ahora sí llevamos el
análisis un poco más allá y por ejemplo
analizamos comparamos los resultados
electorales de las últimas elecciones
ucranianas nos daremos cuenta que todo
el este ucrania no es un territorio que
culturalmente han mantenido siempre
relaciones muy cercanas a moscú es una
población que de acuerdo a ciertas
fuentes en su mayoría es rusohablante en
su mayoría adscribe esta suerte épica de
la gran guerra patria a base fundamental
de la identidad nacional que que pues
promueven vladimir putin y en ese
contexto y yo me pregunto y creo que
corresponde a todos preguntarnos si es
que la realidad política ucraniana de
hoy con el presidente es el inss que un
país que muy completamente viene
combatiendo en una guerra pues contra un
país mucho más grande
una región separatista apoyada por un
país mucho más grande como rusia creo
que hay una suerte de narrativa también
de reacción ante rusia y en ese contexto
el presidente es el inc y yo quisiera
pensar un poco para entender algunas de
las motivaciones de la otra parte es que
acaso el presidente es el inss que
decidió ser presidente solamente de los
pobladores de ucrania que se identifican
con la europa con los derechos civiles
digamos alemania-francia
dejando de lado a esta otra porción de
ucranianos que son también ucranianos
pero que se identifican con la ética
militar los triunfos los grandes logros
de la unión soviética es un hecho
sumamente complejo porque desde otra
perspectiva podríamos decir esas
poblaciones en el marco de este país que
viene sufriendo una guerra brutal hace
años también podrían haberse visto
abandonadas
y pues da pie al argumento de vladimir
putin que intercede por ellas no
solamente en toda guerra la primera
víctima es la verdad pero es importante
reconocer que aquí estamos pisando
terreno un poco
pantanoso al momento de hacer un
análisis fidedigno de la realidad si es
difícil de analizar la situación
ucrania es un país sumamente extenso
justamente el este es la zona donde
concentra mayor cantidad de población y
culturalmente se diferencia mucho del
oeste que siglos atrás perteneció al
imperio austrohúngaro hay una
identificación cultural más cercana con
la cultura germana también con la
cultura húngara hay varios poblados que
hablan húngaro en el oeste de ucrania y
es mucho más agrícola y menos
desarrollada que el este del país hay
una gran diferencia entre las dos
perspectivas de país que se ven desde un
lado y desde el otro y en la mitad está
kiev uniendo prácticamente esos dos
extremos
indicó la el reconocimiento que se le
puede dar a estas dos repúblicas me
lleva un poco a pensar en ese guión que
vivimos hace algunos años 2008 si no
estoy mal con la llegada de tropas rusas
al norte de georgia y también la
proclamación y también la aprobación de
estas dos repúblicas de osetia del sur y
abjasia que hoy en día están en el limbo
se independizaron de georgia recibieron
el apoyo de rusia y solamente las
reconoce un puñado de países entre ellos
venezuela pero internacionalmente no
existen para el escenario internacional
esto puede ser el guión que se puede
avecinar para donestsk y lugansk
es muy posible por kim aventurarse con
este tipo de reconocimientos yo creo que
ni siquiera china va a hacerlo y no
podemos olvidar pues eso fue el día de
ayer cuando en la conferencia de me dije
entonces seré el ministro de exteriores
de china entonces dijo que ellos no
reconocen este tipo de tres
intervenciones a la soberanía integridad
de otro país que ellos no nos van a
reconocer este tipo de actos pero
realmente el problema viene en que es el
objetivo de lenski
es de lenski también este fin de semana
en múnich en esta conferencia de
seguridad lo que dice es que mira yo no
quiero convertirme en mi país como él
colchoncillo entre rusia y el occidente
a mí no me hagan eso ustedes a mí me
dijeron en 2008 en bucarest que yo voy a
ser miembro de otras señores entonces
ahora díganme cuánto
entonces este tema sigue es el que más
sigue y que van a ser las acciónes
entonces esto va a estar muchísimo más
profundo que lo que es realmente está
ocurriendo en jugar en georgia indicó y
eso me lleva a la siguiente pregunta y
quiero que el armemos entre con ustedes
dos analistas sobre este tema y es que
pasó va a seguir ucrania porque como lo
hice indicó el gobierno ucraniano del
momento liderado por la dimensión lens
que le apuesta y le sigue apostando a
seguir parte de la otan a intentar a
entrar a la otan pese al precio que haya
que pagar y no quiere ser ese país
bisagra entre europa del este y rusia
simplemente quiere ser un país con miras
mucho más europeas pero cuál puede ser
entonces el siguiente paso que puede dar
kiev desde su perspectiva
pues quiere lo que va a decir es que
quiero ustedes me hablaron sobre
sanciones
dónde están las sanciones lo que europa
puede decir es que bueno entonces es un
conflicto armado entonces es una
intervención en el territorio hasta
ahora lo que josé morel dijo es que esta
situación de reconocimiento de estos
territorios la independencia por parte
de rusia le da la posibilidad para que
perder
en la mesa las posibles sanciones
es lo que vemos en este momento claro
pero que haya estas sanciones porque yo
creo que es lo máximo lo que van a pedir
los ucranios ellos saben que están
perdidos porque por por todas mayores no
han iniciado guerras hace muchos años
cuando las guerras se iniciaron con más
facilidad claro entonces esto máximo lo
que pueden esperar sanciones contra
rusia y dame plática porque la economía
ucrania está en ruinas estas son las dos
cositas y que la unión europea puede
intervenir un poco más de cerca en kiev
y ayudarles en la parte económica o en
la parte de bienestar social tal vez tal
vez puede ser aún un as bajo la manga
rodrigo su perspectiva
es interesante reconocer también los
argumentos de vladimir putin en un hecho
muy sencillo no para el gobierno de kiev
la ocupación militar de crimea por parte
de rusia territorio que sí ha sido
anexionada la federación rusa constituye
un acto de agresión militar que está
sucediendo ahora mismo mientras tenemos
este debate en el contexto de que el
presidente del inss que fuera exitoso en
sus aspiraciones de unirse a la otan
estaríamos pues este en europa en una
situación jurídicamente que obligaría a
la otan a defender a su estado miembro
dígase en este caso ucrania para liberar
su territorio de la ocupación militar de
rusia en este contexto y yo creo que así
lo han interpretado alemania y también
francia y de ahí a que el apoyo de estos
países busquen mucho más antes que
armará kiev bajad es escalar la crisis
tiene que ver con que nadie en ninguno
de estos estados europeos verse
arrastrado y creo yo tanto que eeuu
quieren verse arrastrados a un conflicto
militar con moscú por ucrania y en este
contexto creo que la opción esbozada por
el presidente macrón duramente criticada
en ucrania de hablar de una suerte de
finlandés acción de ucrania podría ser
relevante en el fondo creo que lo que
estamos viviendo lo que estamos
contemplando es el regreso de rusia el
cambio de paradigma que heredamos de la
derrota de la unión soviética tras la
guerra fría en el sentido de que rusia
está nuevamente en condiciones de
decirle al de decirle al occidente de
presentarle a occidente 'hechos
consumados'
estos son mis intereses geopolíticos y
estas son mis líneas rojas y si ustedes
quieren oponerse pues aténganse a las
consecuencias
rodrigo es que si uno mira los
argumentos dentro de todo el abanico de
argumentos que ha dado rusia a lo largo
de esta escalada siempre han puesto por
delante esa falta de compromiso
para cumplir acuerdos referente a la
expansión de la otan y hoy el presidente
putin lo volvió a decir y dijo que
quería regresar a las fronteras de 1997
que fueron pactadas en ese entendimiento
en ese acuerdo entre rusia y la otan que
no se van a expander más hacia el este y
que ucrania y que rusia no iba a tener
fronteras con algún país perteneciente a
la otan claramente todo esto ha cambiado
y vemos como los tres estados bálticos
tienen
membresía en la otan vemos como el
despliegue de tropas alemanas en
lituania como hay tropas
del reino unido- en estonia que tienen
frontera con la federación y con el
enclave de kaliningrado es claramente un
argumento válido desde el punto de vista
de moscú porque no se le respeta eso a
la federación y porque occidente no
responde por esas acciones indicó
qué
mira yo estoy muy muy de acuerdo en la
línea lo que está diciendo rodrigo es
que rusia en este momento está mostrando
que llegamos a los límites la pregunta
qué porque esto mismo no ocurrió en 2014
entonces porque esperamos entonces hasta
este momento en 2022 muy probablemente
porque porque es rusia está tomando
prestada la ventaja que hay una china
parada en al lado de ellos que tienen
uno de los estados unidos pues en una
situación de su de su de su política
interior y etcétera entonces si exterior
afganistán es quebrada y hay una
situación en europa con unos unos
conflictos grandes entre la francia al
maniatar entonces ve que ahora sí que es
el momento para que se den cuenta de
estos no no si no no más
pero por otro lado cómo está el
compromiso especialmente los países
bálticos y estamos llegando también pues
lo que es porque uno podría decir a
dónde termina este colchón de los rusos
termina en polonia termina en república
checa eslovaquia hungría todos vamos a
convertirnos en ete 8 nos dijo que tanto
colchón necesita además puede saber de
qué mundo estamos en qué mundo estamos
entonces también por lado del occidente
entonces ahí está es que si esos países
bálticos son parte de la unión europea
la unión europea no tiene una política
lo de seguridad lo que realmente le
daría seguridad a estos países en europa
otan lo que da la seguridad a estos
países no la unión europea significa que
donde hay unión europea pues en la
porción lo que seguridad viene de votar
entonces eso los rusos lo sabe muy bien
entonces pues hay que mirar lo que yo
pienso entonces esas fronteras a donde
se se desarrollan pero pero realmente
pues los países miembros de la unión
europea
claro sin tener el apoyo dental son
nadie claro y no cuentan con defensa
propia socio todo un tema de debate en
bruselas rodrigo hablemos de las
reacciones a nivel internacional de
estados unidos ha dicho que está
comprometido con la integridad
territorial de ucrania washington
dándole su total apoyo a cell en esquí y
aquí en la unión europea ha anunciado
que habrá sanciones serán anunciadas en
las próximas horas
pero justamente la unión europea es un
interlocutor con el que moscú no quiere
negociar si quiere conversar con alguien
lo quiere hacer es con washington no le
ha dado la importancia y el peso
necesario a la unión europea que
reacciones podemos esperar en las
próximas horas por parte de occidente
por parte de china por parte de la unión
europea
por supuesto santiago nada más un
acápite para complementar lo que dijo mi
colega indicó jefe que en los años 90
cuando digamos cae el castillo de la
unión soviética aborigen sin contó como
un socio estratégico con el presidente
bush para reformar la economía de rusia
y hacer de rusia un socio de los eeuu
lamentablemente algunos círculos
militaristas que pues tenían también sus
propias agendas en estados unidos vieron
la debilidad rusa de los años 90
consecuencia natural de la nivel
liberalización económica de lo que fue
el régimen dado es el planificado
sistema soviético como una oportunidad
para mejorar la seguridad geopolítica de
los eeuu
de rusia es por eso que la otan ha
llegado hasta las mismas fronteras de
rusia que sucedió cuando rusia o la
unión soviética en los años de kruschev
pretendió llegar a las mismas fronteras
de los estados unidos con la crisis de
los misiles en cuba
la reacción del presidente kennedy fue
decidida y legítima con la crisis de los
misiles hace poco leía unas
declaraciones ya hace algunos años de
barack obama que decía que rusia no era
más que una gran gasolinera que vende
armas eso tampoco es verdad y rusia es
un país que ha contribuido a la
civilización ya la historia universal es
el país que prácticamente acabó con el
nazismo y es un país que merece un
respeto
determinado que creo yo probablemente
putin va a obtener un poco de manera
brutal con esta escalada en la que en el
fondo no sabemos qué es lo que realmente
va a suceder yo creo que acá lo que va a
solucionar el problema y a lo que apunta
realmente hemos esa una
moscú y washington tal y como teníamos
estas cumbres en la época de la guerra
fría porque lo que putin quiere
conseguir es nuevamente ese estatus que
rusia perdió en los años 90 al estatus
de paridad es eso es lo que putin busca
y para eso por supuesto tiene de cerca
el apoyo de china la unión europea en
este contexto militarmente está sobrando
la conversación definitiva será entre
moscú y washington bueno y donde queda
entonces en ese escenario la diplomacia
hay más espacio para la diplomacia se
perdió ya con con los hechos sucedidos
hoy en moscú y esta y estos anuncios
hechos por el kremlin como lo ve indicó
debe haber espacio para la diplomacia
existe una situación pero yo espero que
eso no va a ser el futuro del mundo
donde empezamos a tener bloques otra vez
locas vamos a tener el bloque de los
eeuu con base y con aliados de los
países democráticos y vamos a tener el
otro bloque lo que va a ser el bloque de
china con rusia entonces quienes dicen
que yo son democráticos ellos dicen que
son democráticos pero ellos tienen una
democracia functional
entonces si vamos a tener esta división
gigante una nueva guerra fría entonces
en él en el mundo significa que
de todos modos detrás de este
reconocimiento
nuevo reconocimiento de rusia
y china está pidiendo su reconocimiento
geopolítico y ya entonces de todos modos
detrás de eso no es tan fácil que hay
que pobre rusia que la posta rusia y
china son los países los cuales en el
sentido como se entiende la democracia
liberal no son países democráticos
entonces es mucho más quiere conocer la
grandeza de un país la geopolítica y ajá
eso es el futuro el futuro de la
democracia literal claro sería entonces
le doy la palabra ahora rodrigo
reconocer en dos gobiernos dos sistemas
que tienen en el caso de china un amplio
desarrollo económico ha mejorado
considerablemente las condiciones de
vida de sus habitantes allí pero un
gobierno de mano dura y eso pondría en
entredicho muchos valores de occidente
los valores democráticos y estaríamos
haciendo un parteaguas como dice el
disco bloques como lo veo usted
indudablemente santiago la consecuencia
inmediata de este renacimiento entre
comillas que putin quiere dejar como
legado de su mandato en rusia es esa la
consecuencia lamentablemente la nueva
división del mundo en áreas de
influencia
la pérdida podríamos llamarlo de manera
un poquito más académica
realidad unipolar que vive el mundo tras
el fin de la guerra fría por supuesto
estado de rusia y china- no son estados
democráticos de acuerdo a los parámetros
occidentales liberales pero lo más
triste es que tanto china como rusia
también pueden elaborar dentro de sus
regímenes autoritarios críticas a la
democracia de los eeuu y también a la
democracia y el proceso de integración
de la unión europea cada parte tiene un
argumento que explotar
implementable mente cada parte tiene
también sus intereses creo que parte de
la solución radica en intentar
entenderlos
todos y cada uno de ellos para
resguardar la paz es fundamentalmente lo
que tenemos en el contexto actual de
este mundo nuevamente multipolar
claro y con un modelo como por ejemplo
el chino a nivel económico bastante
exitoso envidiado por muchos países algo
que no ha podido hacer rusia que sigue
teniendo problemas económicos en algunas
áreas pero ya lo vemos tiene un poder
bélico y militar que sigue siendo
importante a nivel internacional me
quedan ya pocos minutos para finalizar
el programa quiero que hagamos las
conclusiones de lo que pueda suceder en
las próximas semanas esta historia este
capítulo de esta escalada de tensión y
de desinformación porque también hay que
decirlo sobre esta situación en ucrania
en cambia todos los días que creen
ustedes que puede suceder reacciones
desde donde que empiece a escalar un
poco o que esto simplemente tenencia o
más las líneas diplomáticas entre moscú
y washington y bruselas comienzo con
indicó
yo creo que van a ver otra vez altibajos
cambios de un día al otro
la unión europea con los eeuu tiene que
ahorita salir con algunas sanciones
como útil hizo esta decisión de hacer
una determinación de su posición si la
unión europea y los estados unidos no
sale con alguna sanción eso es realmente
va a ser una pérdida de cara en vez de
impresionante entonces algo de ahí tiene
que ocurrir claro cuándo vamos a tener
este cumbre entre los eeuu y pueden sí y
rusia yo creo que ahí vamos a esperar un
bastante pues un tiempo largo eso yo
creo que tienen que bajar un poco las
tensiones yo esperaría que china va a
quedarse como que calladito y entonces
macm ok que preferirá a no decir como
mayores cosas
pero quien pierde muchísimo en esto yo
creo que es es francia
entonces
y ricardo para el cierre su opinión la
conclusión
rodrigo verdad
hace poco me escuche unas declaraciones
del presidente va a ir en que me dejaron
preocupados un periodista le preguntó es
que usted aceptaría una línea roja sobre
que ucraniano se una a la otan y el
presidente by le respondió a mí nadie me
pone líneas rojas yo creo que él está
sometido a una gran presión y es la
presión de un bill clinton un george
bush y barack obama un donald trump que
mantuvieron a rusia callada sumisa que
no dio problemas y joseph biden quiere
decir a mitad joe biden quiere decir a
mí tampoco me van a dar problemas estos
tipos no son ricos tienen que quedarse
en sus fronteras a mí no me van a
complicar por suerte de la unión europea
hay que tener cuidado de que este
conflicto no revele las debilidades de
la unión europea no la unión europea
está intentando mediar pero renuncia no
le hace mucho caso y ya la unión europe
está complicada por una serie de
materias sin entrar a hablar de la
independencia energética del continente
que depende ampliaciones de reducción
pero espero que la unión europea
mantenga
la objetividad en este problema y aspiro
también a que rus la reloj rusia se ve a
una movilización quizás sea sociedad
civil y que prime la vida la vida
rodríguez los lados que podrían podrían
perecer en un eventual conflicto militar
ojala indicó les agradezco se me acaba
el tiempo de dar paso al informativo
muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros y analizar este tema para la
audiencia de france 24 ustedes pueden
seguir dejando los comentarios en las
redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]